well let's start with you and um what
inspired you to write this project uh
thank you so much I I I I also want to
say this just briefly about the start of
this project and how it all came
together uh Allan and I were close
friends at film school and he's the
cinematographer and we were working on
our this film together and that's when
he fell in love with johnv and they got
married and John's our producer and she
quickly became part of the team and we
became a family uh and when I started
writing the script uh this was always
the team that we were going to do this
with these three friends from Film
School the editor Jacob uh we we um my
best one of my close friends from high
school was editing a short film with
Jacob and
he uh he said do you want to see do you
want to see my film The I have the
editor's assembly and I was like don't
show me the editor's assembly because do
your do your work on it first and get
get it to a place where you like it and
then show it to me and he was like no I
think it's like 97% there I met Jacob
brilliant editor he's so so talented for
his age and and we were really lucky to
work with each other we worked at his
parent in his parents childhood bedroom
on weekends when he worked a full-time
job and Julia my I've known Julia since
I was a little kid we were we grew up on
the same street and we um I I I did
didn't know who to do the music for this
movie and one of my one of my roommates
uh said I have I've heard Julia Newman's
music and she's she's the real deal and
so this is all of our first feature
films and I'll talk a lot about a z it
feels like he just called everybody you
knew and we're just like do you want to
make make a movie can you make a movie
what what skills do you have that's how
you have to make movies especially in
the beginning when when you're trying to
scrape these projects together and get
them done and so that's no it's a good
idea and a lot of people have done it
and it works out it definitely works out
um so let's talk about your actor though
cuz he wasn't one friends would not have
been possible without the brilliant
Ezekiel PCO this is I think this project
he's brilliant in it and I really I
think it's just the beginning of what
he's capable of because he has so much
depth inside of him and it is just
waiting to explode and I think you can
see it in some of the moments in this
movie Ezekiel did you get to read the
whole script before saying yes to to
doing the movie yeah I got the audition
I was working at Amazon at the time
dropping off packages and then I was
like I need to I'm G make a movie by the
end of the year and I'm going to deliver
a great performance so then I was like
and by the end of the year I got and
thanks to Augustus and his family for
giving me this platform I've been
envisioning this for a long time now so
now that I'm here I'm looking forward to
being uh a Hollywood star and being a
taking over in Hollywood he manifested
it you guys manifested can you can you
just talk about when you read this
um what what was it about the movie that
made you want to do it that attracted
you to this character and the other
characters well I mean I'm an immigrant
yeah I was born in Mexico in Guerero a
lies and I was brought here when I was
one I was raised in Watts all my life I
grew up a street vendor I I I went
around selling ice cream with my family
and uh it was very hard for me growing
up because I had a lot of limitations so
it wasn't always so easy for me someone
like Nico goes through a lot and they
still have to have strength every day to
help out their family go to school and
maybe try and beat somebody and there's
a lot of kids out there that are going
to be watching this and I hope they see
themselves in this because you know a
lot of people go through this especially
if they're immigrants or if they're not
you know they might just come from
low-income families or uh no
opportunities also it's a love letter to
all the parents out there that work so
hard to give their parents I mean their
kids a better life and yeah hope that's
scene in the
film thank
you uh so in this film there's there's a
lot made of his neck tattoo a lot of
instances where you see characters see
it and kind of go so I don't know if I
can trust this person what um about the
neck tattoo what made you want to
include that as part of his character
it's not a real neck tattoo as you may
not know
but but the neck tattoo for Ezekiel and
I meant his father's initials and it
came from a place of love not of
intimidation or fear and we like that ju
deposition how it to all these other
characters it meant something
intimidating but to him it actually
meant something really personal and so
that's kind of what we were going for
with the tattoo it's interesting cuz um
my brother's a tattoo artist and he has
tattoos all over including like on his
neck yeah and in this day and age so
many people have so many tattoos that I
it made me wonder if people are still
judged for for their tattoos and where
they're at and what kind of tattoos they
are but it but it was so interesting how
like some characters
couldn't really get that this guy was
like a fucking great student that was
going to college but also had this neack
tattoo you know like how could this be
possible it could exist in the same um
in the same person um so let's um talk
to some of your uh crafts people here we
have editor and producer and composer
and cinematographer and cinematographer
dpat we're just talking
about uh the different name outside the
different names for
cinematographers is which is what's used
now but it used to be just like
cameraman or um and how older people in
Hollywood call it different things to
people who have been in the business a
long time um when you talked about the
look of the movie together what was it
that you discussed how did you want this
to look and um how did you create helped
create that um well a big part of it
like any film is just uh working with
the production design te team on just
like what the house looked like cuz this
is a smaller film and that house was
kind of like our whole movie um so we
actually ended up painting a lot of the
walls in the house to have this kind of
like cool blue kind of color so that was
like a big part of just is the house
here in La yeah it's in hanock park Han
park at Jason okay because we needed a
house that had a basement
and as we know from watching zodiac
there aren't many basements in
California
but so you got to have a house that's
built before 1930 and that's historic
neighborhoods like Hancock Park where
there's every single house has a has a
basement in it so that's and we think it
added like this aristocratic creepiness
to the whole movie as well I thought
some of those houses look familiar like
when they're walking through the I used
to live like two blocks I used to live
on the Korea Town side of that's exactly
where we shot yeah yeah okay I was like
that looks like my old neighborhood
um so it was it was all practical
nothing on a set or on a s stage we we
built the basement even bigger oh okay
uh using their garage okay uh because
their basement was it just it wouldn't
have been safe for all of us to be down
there with all the gear and stuff yeah
the house was such that we just it was
impossible to find the perfect house for
the script but we just found the place
that had just enough of a basement that
we could sell it in the film and then
kind of basically once you turn the
corner you go down the steps you turn
the corner as soon as you turn the
corner you're inter
set the the production design is very
seamless so hopefully nobody
realized I didn't
know that's movie Magic right yeah um so
what about you as producer what what
made you when you read the script just
go I need to do this I need to work on
this it's going to be really
special um well I think when the script
came to me I think the mark of really
good script is that you just finish it
all in one go and I'm notoriously slow
at reading but this was like an hour I
was like quick and you know I had known
Auggie through AFI Allan was shooting it
Paulo who's not here who alen's brother
was also producing and so you know I
think it's rare that you make a movie
with friends that's on this scale so I
think it felt like the perfect
opportunity to take that leap from
shorts to Fe teach because we were
surrounded by friends and it was a great
story and you know I was just like okay
this is going to be
fun um what led you to make this into
sort of a mystery
um cuz for a while in the film we're
trying to figure
out and I even thought for a long time
oh this family is definitely pulling
something over oh my God they've
murdered somebody or what made you de
side to sort of put that tension like
that in there my favorite films are
suspense Thrillers that kind of they
they engage the audience and keep you
thinking and you to become become an
active participant in the viewing
experience trying to figure out what's
going on and I think that leads its way
to talking about bigger issues and
topics that that I think uh through this
genre can be can be uh explored in in in
a interesting way
the the challenge with this uh bending
genre story was really in the the music
composition and when Julie and I sat
down to to work on the music we were
like okay how do how do we begin telling
the audience what type of movie this is
because it changes a lot for the Vier as
you said I'm glad you brought that up
because I wanted to
know so how do you with with the music
cues tell the audience um how to feel
about certain things well I think
firstly you have to decide what it how
it is that you want to underline what
the film is already doing right so you
have a couple of choices one you can
score from the perspective of local and
we did try that one of our early cues
that we were trying out was do we score
it in a more aristocratic way but it
turns out that the score functioned more
effectively when we were playing into
and elevating the feelings of mistrust
within the house we wanted to elevate
that feeling of claustrophobia so that
it's
I'm helping you but maybe I'm not right
when you see that tattoo it's that
question of what does it mean and what
is and I think that the film does such a
good job of making these really human
characters and I think part of the human
experience is sadly to mistrust your
neighbor to mistrust the person who's S
standing next to you who you're sharing
a a house with and how can we help push
forward and and bring to this surface
this feeling of discomfort this feeling
of unease of course until we reach the
latter part of the film which is when
you know strings come in for the very
first time where we're sort of indulging
in the feeling of it all but I think a
lot of it is trial and error putting
something up next to picture and
deciding does it work am I bored am I
more engaged so are you all together
director editor and composer all working
together in the same room sometimes
working everything out or is everybody's
job done SE separately so I mean every
movie is different um but on in this
case Auggie and I spent about two or 3
months just cutting it together we we
did a a few passes of the film with no
music at all and then we started to
Pepper in some temp music to get a sense
of like okay are we leading the audience
too much here is this you know revealing
too much information too soon are we
answering questions that we want to save
till later and then uh once we kind of
had a Sol cut we started showing things
to Julia she would send music back we'd
put it in you know the cut would change
and then eventually we'd get to locking
picture and then Julia just took over
and killed it but you created a really
natural sense of Rhythm with the edit I
think people oftentimes don't understand
that it's like you're so responsible for
creating the foundational elements of
what makes a film watchable and then I
think the edit and music really are
trying to dance with one another and
then we're all you know both looking to
Auggie and saying okay okay how can we
help really create a solid and shared
vision for that structure and
Direction have you ever worked in
broadcast journalism oh my gosh people
are always asking me what I'm selling
nothing I'm not selling you anything an
amazing
voice I would buy probably anything from
you I was a musical theater kid forgive
me so that's that's where it comes from
no you have a you have a fantastic voice
I just feel like I want to listen to you
tell me all the news all
day so let's Ezekiel how um let's talk
about you working how do how do you help
your actors get to where they need to be
what do you feel about directing actors
is it one of your favorite parts of
directing it's definitely one of the one
of the best parts because that's that's
like game time you're you're there the
the the money's going out the door every
every minute and and you got to try to
capture what you all came prepared to do
and so that's what's really nice I I
think with with Ezekiel and Vanessa I
got so lucky they they really made my
job extremely easy we we got to rehearse
for like about a week before and really
get into these characters get down
Vanessa's Salvadorian accent and uh
bring a lot of ezekiel's real life
experiences to the to the movie and the
that's nice that you guys rehear it it
completely changed so many hear from a
lot of people that they had no rehearsal
at all they just like jumped into
everything yeah no I I it changed every
scene that we worked on in rehearsal
changed at the script level and then
that changes the whole movie so it was
hugely beneficial what do you what do
you think
Ezekiel it was easy it was very easy I
uh working with Auggie and then having
these people give me like a platform to
like showcase my talent has been very
easy for me and it's what I wanted on my
first film um I just wanted the film to
capture my heart and it did I left the
rib on the table and they allowed me to
work the way I wanted and I also want to
thank uh my acting coach Steve tiur who
helped me out a lot uh Ed Harris who
helped me out with my performance and
it's just been I've been real grateful
for everything that's been going on in
my life uh God never gave up on me I've
been real blessed Ezekiel so when when
you when people are called to the Set uh
the the crew call is usually an hour
before the actors called if the actors
in the first scene and Ezekiel would
show up before the crew and stay after
the crew he was the the hardest working
person because he was there before we
started filming he was there after and
he was just it shows his level of
commitment both to the movie and to his
own craft and yeah it was amazing
dedication
[Laughter]
dedication um so so when does this come
out this comes out no this Friday Friday
November 3rd Friday in theaters AMC
Burbank so please if you liked it please
share tell your friends are you having a
premere screening with all of you at it
and we will we will be there Ezekiel and
I will be there on on Friday night with
another Q&A and he'll be there on
Saturday night for a Q&A and we're
working we'll all be around yeah well
congratulations to all of you and thank
you so much for coming out thank you all
so much thank you
[Music]
everyone